this video is brought to you by squarespace
whether it's your new profession or just a
lifelong passion start your journey to website
glory with squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in the
description below more about them in just a bit
we travel back to egypt in the 2700 bc bish the
first two dynasties of pharaohs got this ancient
civilization through growing pains known as the
early domestic period which saw the unification of
the two lands of egypt through war the innovation
of the hieroglyphic writing system and the
emergence of memphis as the new seat of power now
was time to make way for the old kingdom a new era
that marked the beginning of egypt's first golden
age and some would argue the best of the bunch
it started with the third dynasty a seven
decade period that saw the emergence of
many of the elements which made egypt
unique and still fascinate us today
almost five thousand years later the culture
the unique art style the pantheon of gods and
of course the eternal pyramids
they come from the old kingdom
in a somewhat unusual move we're starting out
with the main event as it were because jose was
undoubtedly the most significant pharaoh of
the third dynasty so what made him so important
well that's easy his pyramid at sakhara the
necropolis outside the ancient capital of memphis
it was the first pyramid of egypt in fact it's
still the oldest surviving pyramid in the world
joseph began his reign sometime around the early
2600s bc succeed in kaiser kenwi the final ruler
of the second dynasty the circumstances are
a little murky but the likeliest scenario was
that jose was his son with queen consort nimathap
now you might be wondering why her father and son
would be classified in separate dynasties and you
can blame anetho for that one if that name sounds
vaguely familiar that's because we mentioned him
in most of our other videos on ancient egypt he
was a priest and historian from the 3rd century bc
who wrote the age of tiaka possibly as an egyptian
counterpart to herodotus and his chronicles
although it has not survived in its entirety the
egyptia was a history of egypt that included
a chronological rundown of all the pharaohs up
until that point which he grouped into 30
dynasties modern historians realized they
needed some classification system for all of these
dusty mummified pharaohs so they adopted beneath
those divisions since he'd already done all the
hard work even if some dividing lines between
dynasties seem just a little bit random starting
with jose is the most commonly accepted version
but truth be told we are stumbling around
in the dark a bit by that we mean that jose
might not have been the first pharaoh after all
according to some scholars there are several
surviving artifacts such as the abardos king list
the sikhara tablet and the turin king list that
egyptologists rely on to establish the timeline
of the pharaohs they all name the rulers in
chronological order and literally no two are
the same sometimes the order is different
sometimes the names are different some mention
five pharaohs in the third dynasty others only
four it's all a big jumble that egyptologists have
been trying to untangle for centuries but there
are still gaps wide enough that you could park an
affordable family-sized sedan in them especially
when talking about the earliest dynasties now
it seems joser inherited quite a wealthy and
thriving kingdom he was able to enact multiple
ambitious and expensive projects during his reign
which lasted between two and three decades we
have limited info on his military career but it
seems that his main concern was to strengthen
egypt's borders although he didn't shy away
from the occasional scuffle with his neighbors
during his reign jose expanded his borders both
to the east into the sinai region and to the
west into libya securing egypt's position as
a dominant regional force during its early history
one historian said that joseph's time as pharaoh
was defined by the construction of architectural
monuments agricultural developments trade and the
rise of cities his greatest passion was to build
stuff and we're not just talking about his pyramid
joseph constructed many temples including one that
stopped a deadly famine that was withering away
his entire kingdom this story has survived through
the ages thanks to the appropriately named famine
stella a inscription found on sahel island near
the city of aswan once the main southern frontier
of egypt sure it was made during the ptolemaic
dynasty which was 2500 years after jose but
well let's go with it anyway according to the
stellar a severe drought caused seven years
of famine in egypt during jose's reign children
cried youngsters fell the hearts of the old were
grieving courtiers were needy temples were shut
shrines covered with dust everyone was in distress
some could only crumple to the ground in desperate
prayer while others resorted to theft and murder
in order to get their hands on what little food
was left meanwhile the pharaoh could only watch
helplessly as his people withered away and
died then one night joseph had a haunting
dream where he received a visit from knum the
god of fertility credited with the creation
of the nile knum revealed to the pharaoh that the
famine was punishment for the people of egypt for
giving him the cold shoulder and allowing his
temple on the island of elephantine to fall
into disrepair joseph vowed to correct this
injustice so he sailed to the island himself
he didn't just spruce up the old temple with a
shiny coat of paint instead he built a brand new
temple bigger and better than ever happy with
his new place of worship kunum ended the famine
and joseph was hailed as the savior of his people
some of you might be raising an eyebrow thinking
that this is clearly a legend and you're probably
right however it serves as a good indication of
joseph's reputation among the ancient egyptians
since even thousands of years after his death
he was still regarded as a hero but now we arrive
at the highlight of his reign his pyramid during
the first two dynasties pharaohs were buried in
mastabas which were rectangular tombs dug into
the ground with sloping walls and a flat roof
even though some of them were pretty big with
enough room to bury the pharaoh and hundreds
of his servants they lacked the complexity and
ambition that we associate with the final resting
place of the pharaohs most importantly they were
made from mud bricks and wood so they didn't
last very long sure every now and then the
occasional limestone was used but this was very
much the exception rather than the rule but then
when it was time to begin work on jose's tomb his
advisor imhotep had a light bulb moment why don't
we make it all out of stone the pharaoh liked this
idea so he named imhotep his chief architect and
put him in charge of building his tomb imote
being the clever guy that he was had another idea
what if we put another slightly smaller mustaber
on top of the first one and then another even
smaller one on top of that one and then another
one i'll tell that one six years later we had the
first egyptian pyramid and probably the first
large-scale monument in history made entirely
of stone standing over 200 feet high it was the
tallest structure of its time the complex which
surrounded it also included a mortary temple
several courts a large trench and a thick wall
with a long colonnade that connected the entrance
to the complex to the interior structures suffice
to say ancient egyptians had never seen something
on this scale before and they were left completely
in awe they liked it so much in fact that they
had started worshiping in hote and a couple of
thousand years later he was fully deified as the
god of medicine equated to the greek god asclepius
ultimately joseph's step pyramid was overshadowed
by the stature and resplendence of the pyramids
of giza but his reign was undoubtedly a landmark
moment in history as are the structures that came
to define their civilization now we'll get back to
today's video in just a second but first a quick
word from today's sponsor squarespace it's the age
of creation think about it everyone is out there
on the internet making something blogs websites
online stores youtube channels you've either
got a great idea yourself or you probably know
someone who does and when it's time to get that
idea onto the screen in front of you well if you
need a website that's where squarespace comes in
it's the perfect web tool to help you fashion the
internet into whatever you want it to be maybe the
sort of hands-on type with lots of opinions and
ideas about what exactly your website should look
like if so very cool squarespace gives you all of
the customization options you could ever want with
no updates no patches no technical bs to worry
about or maybe you just need something functional
something that works with minimal thoughts so you
can focus on the content and not just the code of
paint just use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh and
simple and looks like it was made just for you and
once you're done setting up your website locking
in your name maybe playing with some of the
colors if you're so inclined there are a ton of
extra features so that your site can thrive email
campaigns patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options three people having customer support
everything you need in one place so when you're
ready to get started on the next project of yours
big or small if it involves a website it's got
to be with squarespace you go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 off your first purchase of
a website or a domain and let's get back into it
of course the problem when you start at the
top is that there is nowhere to go but down
joseph's successor didn't really live up to the
high bar set at the start of his dynasty his name
was sahemket sometimes also jose tereti
and we guess that he was joseph's son or
perhaps his younger brother so kemket is
so obscure he's one of those pharaohs who
is basically just a name inscribed on an ancient
wall and the main reason why he failed to make a
long-lasting impact was his short reign going by
the various king lists he only ruled as pharaoh
for six or seven years but he did leave one
thing behind which is worth talking about
his unfinished pyramid clearly jose's fancy new
tomb was a big hit and the pharaohs who came
after him tried to follow in his footsteps so
kem ket started construction on his own pyramid
right next to that of jose in the necropolis
of sakhara but he didn't want his pyramid to be
just like joseph no no no no that wouldn't be
good enough he wanted it to be bigger because
when it comes to pyramids bigger is always better
according to inscriptions it was imhotep again who
designed it so unsurprisingly the construction was
similar however because sekhemket reigned just for
a few years only the base was completed by the
time of his death if finished sekemge's pyramid
would have been around 230 feet tall almost 30
feet taller than jose's pyramid but since only the
bottom layer was constructed sakamget's pyramid
was basically just a fancier mastaba made out
of limestone instead of mud bricks unsurprisingly
his successor felt no obligation to complete it so
the unfinished structure was quickly engulfed
by the desert sands and wasn't even discovered
until the 1950s speaking of successes we arrive
now at the most contentious part the elusive
third pharaoh of the third dynasty generally we
know him by the name synacts though he sometimes
is identified as nebucha so far this isn't so
confusing or controversial since pharaoh's had
multiple names but we also have some inscriptions
that identify nebker as the first pharaoh of the
dynasty instead of jose so is it possible that
synacte aka nebca could have been the founder
of the third dynasty as we said most historians
say no but we could pour a little gasoline onto
this controversial fire by pointing out that
sanak was the only pharaoh of the third dynasty
not to build a pyramid for himself or at least try
to like semket instead he opted to be buried in a
traditional mastaba which would be more likely if
he predated jose and his step pyramid that's about
all we know about synact except for the recent
news that he may have been a giant this little tip
it comes to us courtesy of scientists who analyze
the skeletal remains we think may have belonged to
some act while we cannot tell you for certain that
they are his bones we can say that they belong to
a very tall man he stood six feet one inch tall
at a time when the average man was almost a whole
foot shorter medical experts who inspected the
bones believed that his extraordinary height was
caused by gigantism which would make senect
the first diagnosed case in medical records
already we're in the final stretch for the third
dynasty in surprise surprise we arrive at another
pharaoh who was a shadowy figure known mainly as
a name inscribed on a few walls and a few bowls
carver like sikkemcat it seems that kaaba had
a short reign of around six years but unlike
secamkett there is some evidence not a lot but
it's there that the ancient egyptians might not
have been big fans of kaaba they tried to erase
his name from a few places and as we know by now
this practice of damnatio memoria or condemnation
of memory was reserved only for the naughtiest
rulers the ones who cut up two shenanigans that
the people really didn't like such as trying to
abolish all of the old gods and institute a
new monotheistic religion we're looking at
you akhenaten when you also take into account
that kaaba had a short reign it could suggest that
whatever he did may have angered the egyptians
enough to overthrow him also like cecamket kaaba
left behind an unfinished pyramid although for
reasons known only to him he didn't consider
sakara a suitable place for his tomb maybe he
simply didn't want to be overshadowed by jokes or
maybe this was part of whatever he did to
ruffle everyone's feathers but kaaba selected
a new spot for his eternal slumber at zawayet
el ion necropolis across the nile from memphis
their construction began on a new step pyramid
using almost the same architecture as cecamked's
unfinished pyramid today the structure is known
simply as the layer pyramid and it lies in ruins
with only the base till standing today scholars
still can't decide whether the pyramid was ever
finished or not some believe that work on it
was simply abandoned once carber died others
think that the pyramid was completed and
later torn apart so that the stone could be
reused in other projects both scenarios suggest a
pharaoh who was not very popular with the people
and so we reached the end of the line for the
third dynasty if until this point the order of
the pharaohs has been a best guess scenario
we're fairly certain who the last ruler was
hoony possibly also known as quaharjet he
is mentioned several times as the immediate
predecessor of sneferu the first pharaoh of the
fourth dynasty and he may have been his father
as we saw earlier it doesn't really make sense to
group huni and his son into different dynasties
but we just do as manetho commands apparently
he even gives nice symmetry in relation to jose
as we begin and in the third dynasty with
its most prolific pyramid builder while jose
was a pioneer and innovator who clearly
had the most majestic pyramid in his era
it seems that huni was a quantity over quality
kind of guy also like jose he had a long reign
around two and a half decades that allowed him
to dedicate himself to multiple construction
projects honey broke from tradition and built
multiple smaller step pyramids all over egypt
instead of one big one at zakara however none of
them were exactly show stealers and today they
mainly lion ruins they puzzle historians as to
their true purpose pyramids were built to serve
as royal tombs but since none of them fit the
bill huni's true motivation for them remains a
mystery unfortunately for honey modern scholars
have stripped him of his greatest achievement
the maiden pyramid possibly the most bizarre
structure in ancient egypt the maiden pyramid was
a hybrid it started out as a step pyramid but then
someone thought that it would look better with
smooth angled sides it was encased in a limestone
outer layer and turned into a true pyramid
perhaps even the first true pyramid in egypt's
history however because it was a prototype there
were still some bugs to work out so the outer
layer partially collapsed it was a valuable
learning experience for the egyptians as they
perfected their pyramid building techniques in the
centuries that followed and today we're left with
a strange sight half the step pyramid core exposed
the other half encased in limestone the maiden
pyramid was a grand ambitious project not just
due to the innovative and complex design
but also in its size in its finished state
it would have stood at an imposing height of 300
feet almost 100 feet taller than jose's pyramid
it completely dwarfed anything that came before it
so obviously honey would have earned some serious
bragging rights if he was the one responsible for
it for a while egyptologists generally credited
him with the colossal structure they didn't find
his name inscribed anywhere inside the pyramid
but they found it on a few artifacts and some
nearby moustabas that plus the long reign and
the lack of other suitable candidates all seemed
to suggest that huni was the likeliest culprit
alas scholarly consensus has moved away and today
people usually credit his successor sneferu as the
man behind the maiden pyramid even so some still
think that credit should be shared and see it as
perhaps a father-son project where honey built the
original step pyramid as deferred decided to add
the smooth outer layer it is feasible although it
doesn't explain why oni was never buried there and
why his name doesn't appear on any inscriptions
inside it there is the possibility that sneferu
wanted all the glory for himself and removed
all mentions of his predecessor's efforts but
it seems unlikely the mortary cult dedicated
honey survived for centuries after his death
indicating that he remained a popular pharaoh
among the egyptians and speaking of his death
it ended the 70-year period known as the third
dynasty and ushered in the fourth dynasty the
true age of the pyramids this new era saw the
construction of ancient marvels unlike any that
have come before or after the marbles that still
stand today which is not something that could be
said about a lot of the other monuments from that
time however none of that might have been possible
without the efforts and ambition of pharaohs
like jose or huni the vision and creativity
of men like imhotep the third dynasty walked
so the fourth one could run and we'll get to
that fourth one soon no doubt but for now i
do hope you enjoyed today's video if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for watching